- [Mark] I also got a curry with tendon.
Oh, that looks fantastic.
Okay, I'll get a little bit
of everything in this bite.
(light music)
Good morning, everyone.
It's Mark Wiens with
migrationology.com in Hong Kong.
Ying and I didn't have
the best sleep last night.
We woke up at about 2:30 am
and have been awake since,
but that's not because
the bed isn't comfortable,
the bed is ridiculously
comfortable, it's like a cloud,
but just due to the
traveling and the jet lag.
But the good news is it is
a fresh day in Hong Kong.
We're gonna go have breakfast right now.
Oh, that's the other thing.
We woke up hungry too,
so we've been waiting for breakfast.
And right now, it's 6 am.
(coffee machine whirring)
They have a real mix of food,
from all the different
cured meats and salmons
to jamon, (snickers) more ham,
and then also some Chinese things as well.
This is ham like being back in Spain.
And then we got ham, some salmon.
I got some nuts, some Chinese food,
and this is what I need to try first,
is the shumai.
Mmm.
Oh, huge pieces of shrimp in there.
Then also some braised eggplant, I think.
Mmm.
That is really creamy.
This is Europe and
China on a single plate.
And then we got some dill salmon.
I think I've had my share of
salmon on this trip so far,
and I don't regret any bite of it.
This is a different type of salmon here.
This is so good though
I'm gonna have to go
back for more of these.
Mmm.
It's packed with shrimp.
Breakfast was a wonderful success.
And I like how they also have
coffee you can take to go,
so I wasn't gonna miss the opportunity.
Right after breakfast, I
was thinking of going up
to Victoria Peak, at
least that's what I was
thinking about doing this morning,
but it is rainy, it's cloudy.
There's zero visibility, so I guess
that's not gonna happen this morning.
(ticket machine beeps)
Sheung Wan.
(fare machine beeps)
The weather has not let up.
It is still raining, so we
are jumping on the subway.
We're heading up a couple stations
and on our way to go eat.
(light music)
It looks like it's just
gonna drizzle all day long.
(light music)
(diners buzzing)
We made it to Lin Heung Tea House.
This is one of the classic dim
sum restaurants in Hong Kong.
And what I love so much about this place
is you're just walking along
the street in Hong Kong
and then you come up the flight of stairs.
No matter what time of day you come here
or no matter if it's raining or shining,
there could be, like,
horrible weather outside,
and this place will still be packed.
So you just walk in here,
you find empty tables,
you share tables with wherever
you can find empty seats.
(exhales)
And for ordering here, they
push the dim sum around on carts
and every now and then, they
will bring out a fresh cart
full of steamed dim sum.
And you do have to kind of be aggressive.
So right now, I'm waiting for a fresh cart
of dim sum to arrive, and
I'm gonna pounce upon it.
And then they mark down all that you order
on this check sheet here.
(diners buzzing)
(man speaking in foreign language)
It's just an awesome environment in here,
but it is kind of challenging
because right now,
it seems like they're not
bringing that many dishes out.
So as soon as they bring
out a cart full of food,
you have to run up,
and you're not sure
exactly what they'll have.
I managed to get rice, and
this is in a lotus leaf.
And I don't think it's the
sticky rice that I normally,
like glutinous rice that I
normally really like for dim sum,
but this is maybe a different version.
Rice, looks like there's some ham in here
and some shrimp and egg.
Mmm.
That's just like fried rice
and then maybe re-steamed
in the lotus leaf.
(diners buzzing)
- You want?
- [Mark] What?
- [Ying] Get one, get one.
- I managed to get one of my lo mai gai.
These are not exactly
the ones I really wanted,
but the demand is so high right now
that you cannot be too choosy.
You gotta just take what comes.
But luckily, ah, this is what
I wanted in the first place.
I didn't really want that
fried rice in the lotus leaf.
What I want is lo mai gai,
which is glutinous rice
steamed in a lotus leaf,
and it's one of my absolute favorites.
(snickers) That glutinous rice.
The lotus leaf is so fragrant.
And in here should be maybe a mixture
of meat and also maybe
some Chinese sausage.
Oh, that gooeyness.
Since I've been a kid,
I have always loved to eat dim sum,
and I always used to go to eat dim sum
with my parents and my relatives,
and this has always been
one of my absolute favorite things
maybe in the entire world.
And I'd really like some chili sauce,
but it is very challenging
to get a hold of anyone
to try to get some chili sauce,
so I'm gonna take my first bite
and then I'll see if I
can get some chili sauce.
Oh.
That sums up
comfort food to me completely.
The rice is so gooey,
and it's almost like saucy.
But what I love so much about it
is how that lotus leaf is like...
The flavor of that lotus leaf
is embedded into that rice,
giving it like a little bit
of an earthy green taste.
This is some kind of feet.
And I'm pretty sure it's not chicken feet.
It's either like duck feet or goose feet
because you can see that entire web.
And these look like they
are very soft and tender
and braised for a long time.
That's definitely a web.
It's very soft.
It almost has like a noodle texture to it
because it's so soft.
And then it has that very long
slow braised flavor to it.
That web.
Oh, knuckles.
And then you do have to
remove all those little
foot bones.
This is a huge wrap.
There's, I think, some...
I think it's a Napa cabbage,
and then there's some sausage in here.
There's a mushroom, there's something.
I'm not totally sure what's all in here,
but that is a huge cabbage wrap.
This is gonna be really hot.
And it's kinda falling apart.
Mmm.
It has a little bit of
a ginger taste to it.
I think this piece is fish cake.
I managed to get some shrimp dumplings.
I think these are har gow
fresh out of a steamer.
I need to go look for
some chili sauce though.
Okay, that was only partially successful.
I kinda ran around the restaurant
for the last 10 minutes
trying to find chili sauce,
and I got some kind of red sauce,
and then I also came
away with some mustard.
Mustard I do love.
I'll go for one of the shrimp har gow.
And I'm gonna dip into the mustard.
Mm.
Mmmm.
Just filled with shrimp
and then just with a glutinous wrapper.
Now I'll try some of the chili sauce,
put some of this onto the rice.
Mmm, mmm.
Oh, that is a little bit spicy and sour.
Okay, I've got one final foot to go.
I think I like it better than chicken feet
because there is more skin
to this web than a chicken foot.
I would call that
semi-successful with the dim sum.
And then once you're done,
you take your check card,
and these are all of the
dishes that I ordered
that she marked down.
And then you go up to the front and pay.
This place just has so much character.
The thing is it can be
a little bit challenging
to eat here because you have to really be
both patient and aggressive,
and sometimes you don't get to eat
the different dim sums that
you were really hoping to eat
because, number one,
they just don't come out
and you might have to
sit there for a long time
and wait for it, or, number two,
you get to the cart and
they're already gone.
They've just been pounced on.
But anyway, how can you not appreciate
that exciting atmosphere in there?
Today was one of those days
that I didn't exactly get to eat
all of the dim sum that I
wanted to eat, but that's okay.
You just cannot beat
that classic atmosphere.
From here, I was thinking
it would be a great idea
to go have some brisket noodles next.
(light music)
And they are very, very well known
for brisket noodles and brisket curry.
And they open at 12:30.
It's about 12:15 right now,
and there is a line of about
maybe like 100 people.
(snickers) I'm now trying
to decide right now
if I should wait in line.
I guess we don't really
have anything else to do.
(machine whirring)
(diners buzzing)
We made it inside and we came upstairs.
The wait to get in here
did not take too long,
but luckily, they have a bottom
floor and then a top floor,
and then they really pack
you in here on round tables
and just sharing tables.
And then I just ordered
one of the brisket noodles,
and then also, I got a tendon
with curry and noodles.
(diners buzzing)
It is extremely tight quarters in here,
and we are all eating family style,
but I will do my best
to vlog all about it.
We got two different dishes
to share, Ying and I.
One of them is the brisket noodles,
which is one of their classic dishes,
and that's what they
are very well known for.
But then I also got a curry with tendon,
and I think it came with
some shredded brisket as well
and yeah, I'm about to
dig in to both of them.
I'm gonna begin with the
tendon and the curry,
and then there are rice
noodles on the bottom here,
and also there's pieces of, I
think this is brisket as well.
Oh, that looks fantastic.
Okay, I'll get a little bit
of everything in this bite.
Mmm, yeah, you can smell a
little bit of the curry powder
and like a little bit of a
maybe cinnamon aroma to it.
Mmmm.
Okay, that is awesome, yeah.
Wow, that's good.
Okay, so it's just a little bit spicy.
You can taste that curry powder.
Maybe there is like a star
anise in there as well.
There's also some kind of
an herb taste to it as well.
Yeah, that is ridiculously good though.
That is awesome.
Let me try one of those pieces of tendon.
That is a pretty significant
nugget of tendon.
Yeah, that is good tendon, and it has a,
a gelatinous texture of course,
but it's like it soaked up
all of that curry flavor.
- [Ying] Oh my God.
- [Mark] Let me try to dig down now
into those noodles below there.
Mmm.
That has a really nice, like,
herb curry flavor to it as well.
The classic brisket noodles now.
I just gotta have a piece
of that brisket first.
Oh wow.
That brisket is amazing.
It's tender, but it has like a little bit
of a stringy texture to it.
You can taste the beef in it,
and then it just tastes like here,
with the green onions and then...
And I think that broth
is just a very kind of
plain soothing broth, but
it's all about that brisket.
(slurps)
Let me grab that spoon
and I'll just taste that soup.
Mmm.
Okay, actually tasting
the soup on its own,
it has a very, very rich flavor to it.
I think it's beef-based.
I'm not really sure, but it does have
like an umami component to it.
It's salty.
It's a little bit sweet.
And yeah, you can taste that meatiness.
I'm gonna try some of this chili sauce.
Mmm.
Oh, that chili sauce is good.
It's salty and a little bit spicy.
It goes great with that beef.
- [Woman] Okay?
- [Ying] Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay, thank you.
- [Woman] Buh-bye,
buh-bye, buh-bye.
- Thank you.
- Exit is on the right side.
I'm glad we waited in line.
And the line didn't take too long.
So even if you see a
line when you come here,
don't be intimidated.
It goes pretty fast because
they just cram people into the restaurant.
I think we were sitting at
just a little round table.
It couldn't have been more
round than my arm span.
And they put six of us on that table,
and then the entire place was just packed.
And then people mostly just go in there
to slurp down their bowl
of noodles and then leave,
so the line goes fast.
I think I would go for the...
Actually, I liked both of them,
how they were so different,
but the curry noodles with that tendon,
that was the winner for me.
(light music)
Since we are in this area,
I thought we would stop by a temple next,
which is just down the road.
(light music)
This is the Man Mo Temple,
and it was built between
the years of 1847 and 1862.
It is a Taoist temple,
and it's just surrounded
by sky-rise buildings
rising through the sky.
And I'm gonna go take a
look inside real fast.
It's very peaceful and quiet in here.
And on the top ceiling there,
there are just coils of incense
that just continuously burn.
(light music)
It's not a huge temple,
but on that plaque board behind me,
it says that it's a monument
because it demonstrates
traditional Chinese
vernacular architecture,
and especially the ceramics and the murals
and the architecture of the temple.
Form here, Ying and I have decided
to go back to the metro,
and we're gonna head back to
the hotel for a little while
and try to maybe rest.
We're starting to get sleepy.
Maybe it's that food or
maybe it's the jet lag.
But we're going back to the
hotel for a little while
and then going out again
for dinner tonight.
(light music)
(fare machine beeps)
We made it back to Admiralty,
and all at once, I am
feeling extremely groggy.
(light music)
I slept for two hours.
It was so hard to wake up.
But when I got up, the sun is shining.
It's pretty clear.
So Ying is back at the
hotel, still resting,
but I'm gonna use this opportunity
to go to the top of Victoria Peak
for the view of Hong Kong.
(light music)
My happiness to go to the
top was a little short-lived.
I have been met by a line
that literally stretches down the highway.
There must be thousands
of people before me.
I'm not sure how long it's gonna take.
I would just walk to the top of the hill
because I like to hike,
but I wanna take the
funicular, the Peak Tram
for the experience to ride up
because it's a real classic funicular.
So I'm gonna stand in line,
see how fast the line goes.
I guess I am not the only one
who waited out the rain this morning
and waited for sunshine this afternoon.
I have decided to ditch the tram.
That's gonna take hours to wait in line,
and I think I can make it up by walking
maybe in less than an hour,
so I'm on my way hiking.
Plus, I could use the exercise.
Hello.
- Hi.
(light music)
- It is incredibly humid in Hong Kong.
I'm starting to drip with sweat.
But I am very glad I made
the decision to walk.
I'd much rather be hiking
and getting a workout
than standing in line
waiting for the tram.
(light music)
The sign back there said I have
a 30-minute walk to the peak
but I'm not so sure I took
the most direct route.
I was trying to follow
the funicular at first,
but then it got all
confusing in the lanes.
But anyway, I am on the right course now.
(light music)
I made it to the top of the peak.
I am just dripping,
covered in sweat right now.
But I am very glad that I did not wait
for the tram, the funicular.
That took me exactly 35,
in between 35 and 40
minutes to get to the top.
I did make a wrong turn,
but then I really did
kinda huffed and puffed it
all the way to the top
because I wanted to beat the light,
and there is still a little bit of light.
It's not quite as clear
as it was when I started,
but the view is still pretty spectacular.
This is one of the most
iconic views of Hong Kong
from Hong Kong Island on Victoria Peak,
and you can see all of
downtown Hong Kong Island
as well as the other
side, which is Kowloon.
(light music)
- Okay.
- Nice to meet you, Jeffrey.
- Yeah, nice.
- [Mark] And once you're
up here at the peak,
you can walk around on the edge
and just enjoy the amazing
astounding views of Hong Kong.
Hong Kong really has one
of the greatest skylines
in the entire world.
(light music)
That was excellent.
It felt great to get some exercise
and fantastic views of Hong Kong.
And now time to head
down before it gets dark.
(light music)
What's so amazing about Hong Kong
is that you can actually
hike yourself out of a city.
(light music)
After the hike, I went back
to the hotel, had a shower,
and now we are walking on
our way to have dinner.
(diners buzzing)
Came to this restaurant, yeah,
and I wanna say thank you to Tim
for this restaurant recommendation.
This is a restaurant that serves
all sorts of different dishes.
I ordered three different dishes.
I went up front there and saw a fish.
I think it's a little
red snapper possibly,
and it looks maybe steamed,
so I got one of those,
and then I also ordered a vegetable dish
as well as Hong Kong-style eggplant.
I'll begin with the fish,
maybe dip that into the sauce.
This looks like a fermented bean sauce.
Put that onto my rice,
or maybe I'll just take a bite out of it.
Mmm.
That sauce is very salty.
That needs to be eaten with rice.
(man speaking in foreign language)
(food steaming)
This is the next dish that I ordered.
It came in a flaming hot skillet.
And what type of vegetable
is this, Ying, you know?
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Ying] Yeah.
- [Mark] It's either the vegetable,
I think it's the outer leaves of cabbage.
Yeah, I think that's what it is.
I'm not totally sure.
And then oh, you can really smell
like a fishy kind of aroma to it.
I think these are dry shrimp,
and there might be some
salted fish in here too
and then minced pork.
Let me just taste a bit of this.
Mmm.
The vegetable is still crisp,
but you can taste that
seared flavor to it.
And I think that is like dry,
dry fish or just dry shrimp,
but it definitely has a little
bit of a fishy taste to it,
but that complements it.
It makes it salty, and that
provides all the flavor.
Mmm.
(Ying snickers)
Whoa.
I didn't know I ordered that.
(Ying snickers)
I have to say in all honesty
that I thought this eggplant dish
was gonna be like a braised eggplant dish
in a pot as well, but it's
actually slices of eggplant
which are then coated and
battered and deep fried.
(snickers) And this is
quite a beautiful plate,
and then all sorts of crispies on top.
There are, it looks like dried chilis
all mixed in and green onions.
I'll go for this guy
and maybe black beans.
Oh wow, these are like eggplant...
Oh, it's very light.
I will dip into, I think
this is just soy sauce maybe,
I'm not sure.
(food crunching)
It's really, really crispy on the outside
and then really creamy
and just fall apart tender on the inside.
And as I, like, sucked in,
I could taste those chili seeds.
They have like fumes, chili
fumes coming off of them.
Mmm, it is a little bit spicy.
Those are deep friend eggplant fritters.
Mmm.
All of those green onions and those chilis
and maybe that's garlic on there too.
Definitely the winner of the
meal is that vegetable dish.
It's flavored so nicely
with those dried shrimp.
And on the bottom,
there are just big huge cloves of garlic
which have just been fried
in the oil below there,
and they are barely identifiable as garlic
because they're so soft.
Oh yeah, it just melts in your mouth.
That was a great dinner
friendly staff and great ambiance.
It's a Hong Kong busy environment,
but it was kind of spacious for Hong Kong
at the same time, not too hectic,
good food, especially that vegetable dish,
that was the winner of the meal.
(speaking in foreign language)
Okay, the restaurant is called
(speaking in foreign language),
and they just have me their business card.
(light music)
We're in a taxi and
heading back to the hotel.
I'm gonna end the vlog
for today right now.
Thank you all very much
for watching today's video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
And also make sure you click Subscribe
for lots more food and travel videos.
And also, I wanted to mention
that this entire video series
will be in a playlist, which
I will leave in the link
in the description box below.
So if you haven't seen all the videos,
be sure to check them out.
Thank you again for watching,
and I'll see you on the next video.